And this is probably good human being advice
Not just an entrepreneur and startup and investor advice
The true story of Wine Library TV was
The day that I thought I was going to start it
I thought I was going to do something similar to QVC
And I I don't know if you have a QVC or shopping network in Europe
But QVC in America is a show and they sell stuff through the TV
I thought I was going to do the QVC of wine
The first episode of that show
When that camera went on
and that light went on
I realized that this was going to be on the internet forever
And that I didn't want to just Peddle wine
I decided I wanted to be a value to people in learning about wine
Because I was scared that if I was peddling something I didn't believe in
that somebody would come up to me at a party
and say do you like this
and I'd say no I hate it.
They're like well, you fucking said it was awesome on WineLibrary TV
You're a scam artist!
I'm like "Shit! No!"
So
I was very focused on leveling up
and I really believe the one great piece of advice
If you want to take anything from this talk is
We have to start realizing
that giving and doing things in business
without expectation of return
From the other individual
is probably the greatest leverage
that you could ever deploy in your business life
though it is extremely rare in today's business environment
and it has absolutely been the Bedrock
of what has allowed me to win
All my engagement
all my selfies right over there
and signing books
all the content
I have nothing to sell
I have a book that I fucking sell once every three years for Thirteen dollars
This is not about monetizing an audience
it's about building leverage to build brand
versus sales